so today I'll talk about my work on
bio-inspired design and building
feathered morphing winged robots so
bio-inspired design starts with biology
and birds are pretty amazing creatures
that can fly in just about they can fly
better than just about anything their
size even including a current aerial
robots so for example here's some bald
eagles that can fight and stay in flight
and even Lex come less complex wing
motions such as this paragon falcon and
this Pelican what they can do is they
can tuck their wings and dive at really
high speeds
so this peregrine falcon can fly at
speeds up to 200 miles per hour and the
Pelican can tug in its wings and grab
fish from the air into the water at
Heights up to like 60 feet in Swift's
these are birds that spend most of their
lives in the air and they can even sleep
while flying what they do is they can
finally tune their wing shapes in order
to get the optimal shape for different
wind conditions so these large winged
shape changes is something that we can
call or can be described as winged more
thing and while winged morphing
encompasses any large wing shape changes
my research focuses specifically on
morphing wings that can extend and tuck
during gliding flight and birds can
easily outmaneuver current flying aerial
robots and we can compare the
performance of birds with other winged
robots of similar size using a
five-point scale and so this is how
Falcons compared to say a traditional
quadrotor when we compare them for
robustness which is the ability to
withstand collision birds are much
better at being able to hit things and
carry on with our flight than
quadcopters can also adaptability which
is the ability to change shape in order
to adapt to different wind conditions we
can also compare them for flight speeds
glide ratio and also maneuverability
which includes turn radiuses and turn
speeds and birds are fairly balanced
across all five of these categories
and when we compare them to similar
robots they generally exceed the
performance of robots and especially in
those top two categories the the metrics
of robustness to collision as well as
the adaptability of wing shapes so by
incorporating soft feathered morphing
wings maybe we can help design robots
that can improve in these metrics so I
use biological measurements in order to
understand how Birds accomplish these
wing morphing maneuvers and then we can
also apply that knowledge into designing
robots
so in today's talk I'll talk about how I
took biological measurements in bird
wings in order to design a morphing wing
robot so let's start with the biology
and look at the pigeon wing anatomy so
in the avian wing we have flight
feathers that lie against two major
bones in the wing there's the ulna and
the carpal metacarpus and then there's a
wrist joint that lies between them and
it's actuated with with fast-acting
striated muscles so it's kind of
different than our arms birds have most
of their feathers lie between their hand
and their arm as opposed to having this
additional joint here and the primary
feathers make up the hand wing so these
are the ones that are further out and
then there are secondary feathers that
make up most of the armed wing and this
is what makes up the flying services of
a bird and then all of these flight
feathers insert into a thick ligament
that's called that lies along the post
potato in Maya bio mechanical
measurements I define the wrist angle as
the angle between the two bones the ulna
and the carbon metacarpus and then
that's projected onto the earth that's
on the feather plane and the feather
angles are defined as the angle between
the the feather and the what it makes
with the ulna so for the secondary
feathers that's physically the angle
between the bone and the feather since
they attach but for the primary feathers
I project the axis or the feather as
well as the ulna in order to get the
effective angle between them and this is
just for measurement purposes or for
like modeling purposes and in a
Windtunnel study of gliding pigeons
died long ago by a scientist named penny
quick free league lying pigeons have
been shown to glide in a wind tunnel and
adapt naturally adapt different postures
at different speeds and so what they
tend to do is they like to tuck in at
higher wind speeds in order to reduce
the wing profile drag and then they
extend their flights or they extend
their wings more at slower speeds in
order to create more lift and so this
ties back to that metric of adaptability
of wing shapes to different wind
conditions and so from this study we
know that pigeons do that and they can
adjust their platforms accordingly and
so how pigeons are able to achieve these
wings shapes is is something that I
wanted to investigate and if we can find
that mechanism we can then apply it to
designing bio-inspired robots and we can
help robots become more adaptable so to
get to robotic design I first measure
the biological mechanism that's
happening within the wing that enables
the pigeons to morph its wings and then
from there I can create a model that can
be translatable to the mechanics to
building a robot so in this experiment I
used a motion capture system in order to
measure the locations of the bones
within the wing as well as all the
feathers so I've placed markers that are
tracked that are their marker clusters
that are inserted directly into the bone
which is why I use bird cadavers because
this is a pretty invasive invasive
procedure and then I also place markers
along every feather so these are all
twenty feathers flight feathers within
the wing and what I do is I match the
motion of the wing to each of Penny
quicks flight position flight positions
and so here we see the wing fully
extended with the primary and secondary
feathers in that like fully extended
position we can also pose the feather
wing into the mid tax position as well
as the fully tucked position and I can
track the motion of that but beyond just
threes three poses we are also really
interested in the continuous motion the
ability of the bird to flow seamlessly
across all of these pose and adjust them
instead of three discrete poses so I
animate the wing through its full range
of motion all the way from flexion to
extension
and I'm measuring the position of the
bones and all the feathers as I do this
and I take measurements of three
different individuals with 12 cycles
each and from here we can calculate the
motion of all the bones and the feathers
so from these measurements I can plot
the wrist angle which is the input angle
on the x axis and then I have the
measured feather angle along the y axis
and so plotted here is the average in
the standard deviation for the feather
s10 which is the one closest to the body
I track all 20 flight feathers within a
wing but here I'll plot just a sampling
across the wings so here you see s 5
which is a middle secondary feather this
is p1 which is a wrist weight my feather
within the wrist there's P 5 which is
the mid primary feather and then the
farthest wingtip feather is P 10 and so
with these data we can show we can see
that the relationship between the wrist
angle and the feather angle is fairly
linear so I use a least squares fit to
find a linear transfer function in order
to mathematically map what the predicted
feather angle would be for a given wrist
angle input and since each one of these
feathers is only a function of the wrist
angle we can think about the entire wing
as a system that is under actuated so
just by actuating the wrist angle we can
control the motion of all the feathers
within oping
we can also and another thing is that
these are data from both flexion and
extension and so there's no hysteresis
meaning that even when the bird opens
and closes its wings the feathers move
kind of along the same path in both
directions and we can plot the slopes of
this function of these functions and we
can think about the slopes as a
sensitivity to the wrist angle so
depending on how much the wrist angle
moves will affect how much the feathers
move so feathers closer to the body have
a slope of less than 1 so they don't
move as much when the wrist angle moves
which intuitively makes sense and the
distal tip feathers the ones furthest
out have a really wide range of angles
and they'll move a lot compared to what
their wrist angle
so from these linear transfer functions
derived from the kinematic mod in the
kinetic measurements we can now model
the motion of under a created feathers
and I can use this linear model to
create kind of a stick animation of the
wing and you can think of this as a
rough prototype that lays out the the
robotic mechanism of how to build an
under actuated wing and so here's a
little animation where I have the ulna
the the purple lines representing the
bone with Ola and the carpal metacarpus
in this case I also include a sinker
joint and this finger joint enables that
wider spread of a fully extended wing
but here I have the finger coordinated
with the wrist so really it's just the
wrist as an input angle and then I can
predict where the feathers will be for
every input wrist angle because of the
measurements that I made in those linear
the linear transfer functions and so
here you can see this animated model of
how the feather should flow and at every
input wrist angle and so this is kind of
like the first step to helping me design
a robotic wing but these functions
described how the feathers move within
our wing
it doesn't necessarily dig into why or
how we would actually go about building
something that moves like this so to
understand the implementation of under
actuation under actuated motion I go
back to the anatomy so remember that
ligament and involuntary smooth muscle
that lies net-like lies between each of
the feathers so we can translate that
biology into a mechanical design and I
approximate this as a series of linear
Springs
that's a weave in between each of the
feathers and to test this approximation
I created a model with linear elastic
Springs between each flight feather and
I assume that the flexion extension
happens only within the plane of the
wing that the feathers are each attached
to the bone via a frictionless pin joint
so they only have one degree of freedom
rotating in that plane in the distance
that the spring attachment is estimated
from biological measurements and
additionally that the the Springs all
have a bit of pre tension even in that
tucked flying position so that means
that they're still holding out their
wings in the
tucked position as opposed to completely
relaxed when they're like walking around
with their wings tucked in and now I
also assume that the furthest the
furthest wingtip feather is rigidly
attached to the bone and when in in
biology it really is the bone kind of
fuses around that last feather and that
the the normalized force the force that
it takes for the bird to stretch out and
extend its wings is acting perpendicular
on to that last feather and then for the
other boundary condition closer to the
body there's a lot of other smaller
feathers here and so I model that and
spring attachment as a moving one moving
as the average of the feathers next to
it so I also assume that morphing is
quasi static so every wrist angle the
feather the feathers aren't moving
they're kind of static at each wrist
angle and so for the linear model I know
the position of every single feather for
a given wrist angle and I can also
assume that the sum of the moments
around that feather is zero and so I can
solve for the stiffness of each of the
springs because I know that the springs
oppose each other within the feather and
they sum to zero and so doing this
calculation so this is an example of one
feather but if you do this as a system
of equations across all twenty feathers
I can set up a matrix equation that
allows me to solve for all the different
spring stiffnesses K for each pose and I
can do this for each of the wrist angles
and then predict what the average
stiffness should be between two the
feathers so you can see this plotted
here the bar chart shows the relative
stiffness of the spring between each
feather for each of the feathers and
this is averaged across 151 different
wrist angle poses and you can think of
like the feather positions as the nodes
of the springs as the springs are
stretched from end to end and here you
can see that the lowest stiffness is
between the wrist Engel so between p1
and s1 and this makes sense because
that's where the feathers separate a lot
and you expect to have something that's
less stiff to allow the birds to really
stretch in that ink in that area and
then the stiffnesses are really high at
the wingtip feathers which also makes
sense because you don't want the
feathers separating when you have high
winds
condition so you actually want the tip
feathers to be much more stiff and so
now that we can model the kinematics or
the motion of the center shaft of the
feathers let's take a closer look at the
feather surfaces and that's mostly
because if the feather surfaces that
make up the surface of the wing and that
is the lifting what provides lift for
the birds as they fly so in order to
maintain a continuous wing the feathers
overlap and so in a way that the
outermost feather lies under the next
and so you can see that in the
cross-sectional view on the bottom right
kind of with the the circles represent
the rekha so that Center shaft and then
the vanes that tuck under the next
feather and that means that under
aerodynamic loading the bottom feather
pushes up against its inner neighbor and
so then it's in contact to create a
continuous surface and this is true all
the way across the wing where the tip
feather is nestled under the next all
the way down until the closest one to
the body and so then therefore all the
feathers are continually in contact with
each other and they actually slide
against each other as the bird is
morphing its wings while it's flying so
it seems that feathers and their feather
services are important things to look at
so since feathers are the building
blocks of a bird wing I wanted to take a
closer look to kind of understand what
makes them so special so feathers are
made up of keratin proteins which is the
same as your hair but while hair is
normally just a single strand feathers
are actually highly hierarchical in
their structure so here you can see a
feather where you have the main central
shaft which is the Reyes and then
there's these soft veins on either side
and that's what creates the the
aerodynamic surfaces but if you zoom in
you can see that zooming into this
section you see that central central
Reyes again and then now you can see
closer that the veins are actually made
up of a bunch of barbs that are stitched
next to each other and zooming into that
you can see that each barb has a stiff
Center ramus and then they have
branching barbules that branch off of
that
and zooming into that some more as you
can see exactly how hierarchical these
feathers are but the barbules themselves
also have these branching structures
called cilia and now we're really into
the micro scale and so in these
branching cilia there some that stick up
and out of plane and that's what
interacts with the neighboring feathers
and so we can see how they interact by
taking CT scans of hooks adjacent
feathers and so this is a CT scan this
is a 3d rendering of that CT scan as
we're looking down and you can see how
the p5 feather overlaps the p6 feather
and if you take a cross-sectional view
of that 3d rendering you can see kind of
that might those micro structures
interacting and so there's some bottom
ray my that are like hooks down and then
there's these out-of-plane micro
structures that well you really can't
see in this view because the resolution
of the CT scanner isn't quite good
enough so to solve that problem we zoom
in some more and looking at each of the
individual feathers and this way we can
get a better resolution and so I worked
with collaborator Theresa FeO who imaged
individual feathers using a high-energy
beam line CT scanner at Argonne National
Laboratories and she took small sections
of individual feathers in order to get
that in order to find the resolution to
figure out what the shape of those micro
structures really are like so now you
can see clearly that there's this hooked
bottom edge of the ramus that locks on
to the lobate cilia that stick up and
out of plane and we can render these
structures into 3d forms and you can see
how they interact so you have that
lobate cilia that really is a hook that
sticks up and out of plane and then the
ramus that will scoop in and interact
and we can also use scanning electron
microscopy in order to look down and see
what the surface of the structures are
like and so now we can see them from the
top view looking down as well as zooming
out we can see that there's actually a
field of them within the feather surface
and so you can think of these as a bunch
of hook le'ts
kind of interacting with the top hook
train I and so these are kind of like
probabilistic
fasteners are something that your you're
more familiar with is more like velcro
so the surfaces of the feathers and have
these special micro micro structures
cause them to when they interact with
each other to hook together and moving
and they stick like velcro so we've go
really far deep into the micro structure
so let's let's come back out and try to
figure out like how that affects the
strength the feathers interacting
themselves so in order to test how these
micro structures affect the behavior of
feathers sliding next to each other I do
this experiment where I pull feathers
apart in in four different directions so
in flexion and extension so the usual
extend in tuck positions and as well as
just to be thorough to test the surfaces
moving in the Antarian posterior
direction and so here is a video of
separating feathers as they pull apart
and you can really see that sticking
mechanism happening and that's what
keeps the feathers together and from
falling from pulling apart when the bird
extends its wings and so you see the
forces opposing that motion are really
high and now here's section which is
tucking the wings in and so they slide
with really low forces and same for
testing in the posterior and anterior
direction and so what we found that not
only do feather micro structures have
have kind of this Pablo stick fasting
like velcro it's also highly directional
which is pretty unique and so therefore
that birds are able to keep their
feathers from separating apart when are
they they're able to prevent their
feathers from separating when they're
extending their wings during flight so
let's go back to robotic design so from
the biological measurements of the
feather kinematics we developed a linear
spring model in order and this helps us
design a mechanism to build into a robot
that can actuate that can enable the
wings to actuate all the feathers in an
under actuated way and from diving
really deep into the feather micro
structures and learning about
directional probabilistic fastening we
also realized that feathers are really
unique microstrip are really unique
structures that we can't fully represent
artificially and so this is a big
motivation for us to design these
bio-hybrid wings so using the feathers
in our robotic design so for a robotic
for our robotic wing we use these real
bird feathers in here this is how we
built a robotic wing so we have an
active skeleton and this skeleton
structure is based off of the shape and
motion of the bones and is actuated by
two servos that can control the wrist
angle as well as the finger angle and
these servo powered skeletons control
so it's mimicked Bob off the the
skeleton and then it controls the wrist
and the finger angle and then we also
have a series of these elastic bands and
so this is what we're trying to this is
what we implemented from the kinematic
measurements and each elastic band is
tuned based off the stiffnesses that was
calculated and they make the same the
same the same stiffnesses we also use
real fit pigeon feathers in order to
capture that same property of feathers
being able to slide against each other
and to hook only during extension and so
together the active skeleton and the
elastic ligaments enable the under
actuation of the wing and so here you
can see the robotic wing morphing
continuously as we activate as we
actuate just the wrist and the finger
angles so with this wing we can test
permutations that aren't practical to do
with real birds
so I wanted to ask some questions for
example how does the wing perform under
aerodynamic loading and what are the
roles the elasticity and feather contact
like is it really necessary to have both
and what does that look like when of
when a bird wing is actually
aerodynamically loaded so to answer
these questions we place our wing into a
wind tunnel and here you're looking at
the test section with the wind blowing
from left to right and the wing is
mounted on a splitter plate at 10
degrees of an angle attack which is
similar to what pigeons do when they're
flying we have a camera underneath that
films kind of like the belly up view so
you would see like a bird flying
overhead and then additionally we have
a turbulence grid that is upstream of
the test section and so this has the
spinning vanes that can create a
turbulent different turbulence profiles
so that way we can test the wing in both
laminar flow or slow turbulence and also
high turbulence intensities so to
understand the effects of the elasticity
and feather contact under aerodynamic
loading I test different permutations of
the robot so first I have the original
feather contact where all the feathers
and nestled against each other and then
we also created a different robot in
which we slightly spaced out the
feathers so they don't come into contact
with each other we also have different
permutations where the elasticity are
all in place and the elastic bands are
intact as well as removing them and just
seeing what that happens and so here are
images of the wing under aerodynamic
loading and the fully outstretched
outstretched position and you can see
that you really do need both the feather
contact and the elastic ligaments in
order to create a seamless wing and as
soon as you remove contact between the
feathers gaps start to form between them
and so it really is that fastening is
really necessary to keep the feathers
together under aerodynamic loading and
interestingly if you remove the elastic
bands but keep the feather keep the
feathers in contact you can see that
they tend to stay together but when you
have at the tip feathers where you're
opposing the wind the elastic the
fastening between feathers isn't high
enough so that's where the elasticity
comes into play and then of course if
you don't have feather contact or
elastic bands they really don't they
really don't stay into a wing and so
here is an image of all these different
permutations of the wing morphs within
within a wind tunnel and you can really
see the gaps that's hard to form between
the feathers when there's no contact and
as well as the feathers kind of sticking
together when there's feather contact
but no elasticity shows even bigger gaps
between them
we can also repeat the same for
permutations in turbulent flow and once
again it really is only the wing that
has both the feather contact and elastic
bands intact that stay a continuous wing
so we know that both of these things are
important when we design when we design
a robot and here you can see in that
turbulent wind and the effects of of
these different permutations or a lot
more a lot more prominent and so once
again it really is in order to morph
successfully we have to have the elastic
ligaments as well as the feather contact
coming into contact and so to get a
quantitative measure of the feather
motion of our robot we use image
processing in order to track the feather
and wrist angles as the wing morphs and
so the wrist angle is calculated from
those purple lines and that's and then
the colored rectangular markers that you
see are tracking markers that are placed
on each of the feathers and we can get
the angles we can measure the angles of
each of the feathers within the robotic
wing and so we can we can plot once
again that feather angle along the y
axis as well as the input wrist angle
along the x axis and this is more
quantitative measure of what you could
see the effects in in the video so when
all the lines are kind of equally spaced
with some nonzero slope you can see that
the feathers are well coordinated kind
of like in the case we have both feather
contact and elastic bands when you see
the zero slope so kind of along the
bottom that means that the feathers just
aren't moving when the wrist is moving
and when there's gaps between in the
slope there's like differences between
the slopes that shows the gaps that
happen between you to the feathers and
so we know that we need both elastic and
feather contact in order to have a
continuous plane platform so after a
Windtunnel testing we built a full
morphing robotic wing and we're able to
test it in outdoor flight testing and
more they're actively morph the wings
and so the wing is mounted on a
traditional RC fuselage with a propeller
that provides thrust and the bio-hybrid
robot successfully flies outdoors as its
morphs its wings from the Tuck position
to a fully extended position so in this
video the robot is tele operated by an
operator but we also have an onboard
autopilot as well as a suite of
different sensors so we can do different
controls testing on it as well
and what we also live stream the data
from here to a computer ground station
and we're tracking the flight yeah so we
can we have a traditional tail right now
and so there's a there's mmm we can also
for let's see we've traditional tail so
that's elevator pitch and then there's
yaw and then for roll we can control
like asymmetrically tucking each wing
but yeah we don't have the traditional
ailerons that control roll and for you
don't either
so the in-flight gliding positions of
our robot we're able to replicate the
same positions that were measured by
penny quick for the gliding pigeons so
here you see the comparison for the
fully extended wing as well as the mid
tuck position and fully packed position
and this is also these are three
discrete points but we can also
continuously morph just like birds
between all these positions so the
choice of the pigeon as a model animal
comes from the fact that they're kind of
a generalist bird and they're actually
like surprisingly good at flying in
cluttered environments and surviving in
places you wouldn't expect birds to
survive and you can really you find them
thriving just about anywhere but there
are over 9,000 different species of
birds and each one has really different
flight adaptations so could we use the
same bio-inspired design rules in order
to design if that we discovered for a
pigeon robot in order to design robots
that are more like other species so we
could maybe include Wright flight
adaptations perhaps be inspired by the
California condor and they're really
good at gliding or maybe by owls that
are
Island Flyers so I took the barn owl as
a case study in order to test the
robotic design principles that we found
from a pigeon and so I applied the same
under activated design but adapted for
the alum morphology so it's a different
bone shape in a different different size
scale so vowels are a little bit bigger
and we also adapted it to team use owl
feathers and so as you see here we can
use the same principles in the same
design mechanism in order to create a
wing that can morph just as seamlessly
as the pigeons
so to design bio-inspired feathered
morphing wings I started with the
kinematic measurements of feathers and
also the bones within a wing and then
determined kind of diving deep into the
micro structures determining what the
feather surfaces were like and from
there we are able to combine those
principles from biology to design a more
food wing feathered robotic robotic bird
and so putting that all together we can
design we can go from biology to robots
but kind of another exciting thing is
that from robotics we can also learn a
lot about biology so not only can
biology inform robotics robots can also
help us figure out and answer questions
that we didn't know in biology that we
couldn't necessarily test with real
animals so with that I'd like to
conclude and also acknowledge my
collaborators in my lab mates
Amanda Stowers Erik Cheng Lindsey
Jeffries Teresa Theo as well as my PhD
advisor David Lin tink and I'll stop
here and take questions
[Applause]
yeah it is really cool you have to be
using like that I do something robot
but I guess do you think there's also
any further research they'll be done to
try to make those feathers like with
like materials or so you can get that
kind of class like yeah definitely for
sure so I think kind of from knowing
this design we can also apply different
artificial feather manufacturing methods
so I've actually explored making carbon
fiber feathers and things like that but
if you remember the structures of the
feathers they have this ability to be
really stiff as well as really soft and
nestled against each other and so with
carbon fiber we run into the the problem
of them not being able to press against
each other because they're too stiff so
I think there's a kind of big open field
to creating artificial feathers and
there's a lot of cool things that we
could do yeah
they can a very impressive deep dive is
two functions of the wing and how
they're structured I'm curious if you
explored it all the relevance of the
structure of the bone so yeah there's
the geometry of the bone but also like
the properties and the weight associated
with it does that seem to make a crucial
difference in terms of whether you're
actually able to replicate the behavior
pertinent yeah there's actually a lot of
studies have gone way into like you know
how boned a bird bones are really
different how they're hollow and they're
good at resisting torsion and things
like that another lab mate of mine has
looked at the different mechanisms in
the joint so like a four bar six bar
mechanism to replicate how the bird
skeleton moves for me I was focused
mostly on the feather so I like simplify
all the bone into just moving in as a
wrist angle but that definitely is
definitely just this direction we can go
I think a lot of our energy engineering
materials are good at replicating bone
like the 3d printed parts that we have
here and it's a more simple structure
than the feathers are
with the alan the pigeon model the the
tensions are negative the less
elasticity of the those values or they
are using the same or did you do
comparison between what the pigeon model
preferred for the elasticity and then
the bow yeah so alice actually have two
more secondary feathers and in this case
i used kind of the pigeon as a template
and then adjusted as we went so each one
of those elastic bands have like
different stiffnesses they're like
different diameters or different
thicknesses and so I started with the
pigeon values as a template and then
swapped him out when it looked like
there a gap you're not moving fluidly
so the I think it was like the s6 high
one was like had almost no error to the
measurement yes that was that consistent
without as well and if so is there you
have an insight on why that one was so
so much more precise I think so we
didn't do the biomechanical measurements
on the owls and so I think the idea is
that if we do this really in-depth study
on pigeons can we then translate the
learning to other species without having
to go do these biomechanical
measurements and it's easier to do these
measurements on pigeons and it is on
owls and so for s6 the like the
preciseness I think it just happens to
be yeah I'm not sure why it's
particularly more precise than that in
that case it could be from the three
individuals that I initially measured
yeah I wouldn't focus specifically on
that thank you
you have a sense of the weight compared
to a traditional yeah because we use the
like 3d printed bone mechanism as well
as putting the actuators on the wing
itself it tends to be a little bit
heavier in the skeleton section but then
since we're using feathers which are
really lightweight I think it tends to
be a little bit heavier because the
actuation happens directly on the wing
as opposed to when you have like the
servos in the fuselage and bars coming
out so yes I guess birds naturally
provide their own thrust from their
wings because they flap their wings and
adding flapping wings is like a whole
nother mechanism you have to add on top
of that and I think eventually it would
be something we could do and that's kind
of like in the shoulder joints and
having you know the power within the
fuselage so I think that would be a
really cool direction but certainly a
whole nother PhD project okay thank you
[Applause]